[MUSIC PLAYING]
CORY LEVY: So I will be
talking about teens today.
Thanks for coming.
Over the last month, we've
watched hundreds of thousands
of teenagers organize and
participate in massive rallies
across the country.
They've done this in
the face of both pain
and serious frustration, that
adults have utterly failed them
on something very, very basic.
That's keeping schools safe.
Adults who have been unable
to achieve common sense,
gun control following mass
shooting after mass shooting,
are now placing their hands
in this younger generation.
But isn't this like
the same generation
that made eating Tide
Pods a viral sensation
in recent weeks?
Like, how much do
you really understand
today's young people, and
how much do you even care?
For most old people, the
answer is very little.
They don't care,
but you should care.
This is the generation that
will create massive change
in the world over
the next 50 years.
And for us to be able to
teach and influence them
as they begin to
make those changes,
it's super important
that we understand them.
So if you'll allow
me to be your guide,
I'd like to tell you a little
bit about today's teenager,
but first, a little
bit about me.
My name is Corey Levy.
I'm in my mid-20's,
and although I'll
be using the word we while
I present this information,
teams consider me a little old.
So I've worked years to stay
on top of this generation.
As Jesse mentioned, I started
a company called After School
while I was a teenager,
while I was 19.
After School is one of the
largest teenage social networks
in the US, millions of users who
are currently in high school.
I'm also on the board
of Dosomething.org
which is a nonprofit, a
digital platform powering
social change for nearly
six million young people,
and today, I'm going
to help you understand
this generation a bit better.
So over the last few weeks, I've
been interviewing teenagers,
and with the help from
teens across the country,
I've made a list of ten
things that you probably
don't understand
today about teenagers.
So we'll get started.
The first point is we're
heavily addicted to our phones,
but we don't know our phone
numbers, which the first part,
you probably already know.
The second part was a
little surprising to me,
and how is this possible?
Obviously, you know like
teens grew up with iPhones
and Androids with smartphones.
They're more reliant on
them than ever before,
but teenagers, they care
more about like user names.
What's their Snapchat name?
What's their Instagram handle?
They don't really care
about phone numbers.
When they meet new people
for the first time,
they're exchanging these
handles, not like, hey,
what's your number?
It's like, hey,
add me on Snapchat,
or follow me on Instagram.
They don't use iMessage or
SMS, because Mom and Dad
can have access to that.
They're texting on
Snapchat and Instagram DM,
and they've probably never
used this thing the way
it was invented, which is
they've probably never used
the actual phone.
They've never used
an alarm clock.
They just use their phone
for that, and doorbells,
they're like, what's that?
They're totally
unnecessary, and here's
how like two teenagers
that I interviewed
described their connections
to their phones.
Teenagers are digital natives.
They don't live in a
mobile-friendly world.
They're a mobile-only
generation.
Another person who is
a senior in high school
said, parents just
don't understand
why we move from thing
to thing so quickly.
It's not that we have
a short attention span.
It's our generation's ability
to filter through information
more quickly, because we just
get bombarded with it so much.
This is point number two.
Facebook is lame.
We love streaks.
Teens think Facebook is
for their grandparents.
It's old, clunky, and
invasive, and in fact, it's
one of the reasons that
we developed our app,
After School, which helps
teens connect and share
with other students
at their high school.
Millions of users, we have
like a matching feature
that's connected over--
that's been used
over a billion times,
with a B. We just like
released a compliment
feature in the last 24 hours,
like hundreds of thousands
of teenagers have complemented
each other with that.
And what we've seen with After
School is that teens use us,
because we're like a
teen-only social network
to come to use the product to
post things that they wouldn't
post on Facebook or
Twitter or Instagram,
because there is an
anonymous feature to it.
We also connect teenagers
with Crisis Text Line
when they are in need of help.
Crisis Text Line
is a teen hotline
that you can text 741741.
Instead of like
calling a hotline,
you can text with a
trained crisis counselor.
We've connect over 100,000
teenagers to Crisis Text
Line via our app,
but probably one
of the most popular ways that
teens communicate is snaps.
Raise your hand if you
know what a streak is,
about half the audience.
Teens are like obsessed
with Snapstreaks,
and a little bit of
what a Snapstreak is,
it's when you send direct
snaps back and forth
for consecutive days.
So if me and you snapped
each other today, tomorrow,
and the next day, we would have
had a three day Snapstreak.
And the longer you go
without breaking the chain,
the longer your streak is.
And teenagers today have
like streaks that have lasted
not just weeks or
months but years.
Snap rewards, these longer
streaks like special emojis.
So if you get 100 streak,
you get the little 100 emoji
or like a mountain emoji for
like an extremely, extremely
long streak.
And there's nothing more
devastating to a teenager
than like losing that streak.
When they go off to camp
for like a week or a month,
they'll give their Snap
password to a friend,
just so they can keep
their streaks going.
Here's how a 16-year-old
from Brooklyn put it.
Streaks are a big part
of social acceptance.
Having more streaks makes
you feel way more popular.
He added, I think streaks
are a way of showing
how many people you talk to.
It's like a score.
If you see your friends
have a lot of streaks,
you're like, whoa, that guy
or girl knows a lot of people.
It shows her social status to
see how many streaks they have.
So Snapstreaks is something
that is incredibly
popular amongst teenagers,
and teens also love Instagram,
and Instagram Live is
particularly popular.
This allows them to connect
with their followers
and their audience in real time.
And another like important
trend that's popped up
is something called a finsta.
Raise your hand if you've
heard of a finsta, one,
two people in the audience.
A finsta stands for
a fake Instagram.
So teenagers will have
two Instagrams set up,
one is their main
Instagram, and that's
where their parents, their
siblings, their cousins,
their friends will follow them.
And then they have
a second Instagram
called a finsta which
stands for fake Instagram.
And that's where they just
have their like top friends,
no parents, no teachers, no
cousins that follow them.
A 17-year-old student I talked
to described her finsta.
So she goes, on my finsta,
it's the good, the bad,
and the ugly.
It's the more multifaceted
version of me.
And many teens are aware
that like potential employers
and colleges will have access
to their main Instagram,
so they create this second
Instagram called a finsta
to keep some of the
information private.
A 16-year-old I interviewed
said, people in my IG
are always doing Instagram
Lives, usually for attention.
Something I do unconsciously
is pull out Snapchat any time
anything interesting is
happening, especially
around New York City.
A majority of my videos on my
phone are in Snap memories.
Anytime I take a video,
it's with Snap for sure,
just because it's easy to share.
So teens today aren't using the
default camera on their phones.
They aren't using the default
Apple or Google camera
when they want to take a photo.
They're going to
Snapchat, taking a photo.
And then saving it, and
then debating whether or not
to send it out which was
which was surprising to me.
Point number three, we're
modern-day Shakespeares.
So teenagers are creating new
language every single day,
and we usually start
copying them eventually.
So I want to share
like some examples
of what teens are saying today.
Amosc is an acronym kids
are using to basically
just means Add Me On Snapchat.
Bad means good, surprising.
Bruh means bro.
Cringe is when something
is like gross or awkward
or uncomfortable.
Curve, or swerve sometimes,
is to reject someone.
Don't at me is like
don't call me out
or don't disagree with me.
Finna is like I'm
fixing to or going to.
Finsta, which I just
described, is a fake Instagram.
Goat, acronym that stands
for Greatest Of All Time.
Gucci, not the
brand, it means good.
I'm weak or dead is
like that's so funny.
That's hilarious.
Kms is like the new fml.
Savage is bold or strong.
Low key, you want to
say something low key,
it's like secretive.
And high key, that means
it's not secretive,
and it's something that
everyone should know.
Plug, someone that can
provide them with something.
Shipped, it's not like
shipping a product
but more like a relationship,
like Alex and Sierra should
be shipped-off
together means they
should be in a relationship.
Straight fire is
like good or trendy.
To describe your
friend group, they're
using both squad and fam,
and to be bitter is salty.
Straight fire is
like that's also
another term they use
for good or trendy,
and then sus is a term
they're using for something
that's like suspicious.
So you might hear
a news reporter
in a few months saying like
what Facebook did was so sus.
That's a little example.
So this won't be on the midterm,
but you should definitely
know what teens, the
words that they're saying,
but like teens are
moving beyond words.
They've made popular an array of
new communication techniques--
emojis, memes, gifs-- to
express their emotions quickly.
If you look at any
teen's text conversation,
you will immediately notice the
difference with adults' texts.
Teens use like tons of
emojis, gifs, memes, and this
makes complete sense.
They're use to like a
flood of information,
and have become
like really, really
good at processing it quickly
and conveying ideas quickly.
And it's much more
efficient for them
to use like an emoji or a
gif and like four or 10 words
to describe what they
want to communicate.
Teens, they don't get why
you are so close-minded.
Teens think that adults
are close-minded when
it comes to things
like same-sex marriage,
different sexual orientation,
mixed-race dating.
And this makes sense
when you consider
they're a part of like the most
racially-diverse generation
in America.
48% of them are non-white.
81% of them have friends
that are a different race,
and 35% of them have dated
a different race as well.
One teen put it, most
kids like myself,
and especially ones
in urban environments,
care about the
rights of themselves
but also people that
don't look like them
or share similar attributes.
And that's the reason
why we actually
go out and protest at
city hall, because it's
hard for adults who are stuck
in their ways to see when change
is necessary.
This one may or may not
be surprising to you,
but gamers are
heroes, not geeks.
Teens still love like their
movie stars, musicians,
athletes, et cetera, but
who can be a celebrity
has changed quite some time.
They idolize vloggers
like Jake Paul
who has nearly 15 million
YouTube subscribers
and whose videos are being
viewed billions of times
a month.
I was lucky enough to be
one of his first investors
and his management company,
when he was 17 years old.
They follow entrepreneurs, like
Elon Musk and Gary Vaynerchuk
and Peter Thiel and
Mark Cuban and Tim Cook.
And perhaps, like the
most interesting thing,
they've made esports
figures their heroes.
Esport stadiums are being built
across the country in Vegas
and Houston and Dallas,
and pro video game players
have these massive
followings, like
major corporate sponsorships.
And they compete in
these huge arenas
and make way more money
than like regular athletes.
There's a 26-year-old
named Ninja.
Raise your hand if
you've heard of Ninja.
Two people has heard of Ninja.
He's the most popular
gamer on Twitch
and earns more than half
a million dollars a month
just by playing video games.
Fortnite is a
massive game that's
superpopular amongst teenagers.
Ninja just played Fortnite in
front of 600,000 people viewing
it at the same time.
Drake, the rapper, came
on and played with him.
JuJu Smith-Schuster, a
Steelers wide receiver,
came on and played with him.
This is something that is just
at the very, very beginning
and continuing to blow up.
One team put it, while athletes
and movie stars are still
famous the idolization of
entrepreneurs, like Gary,
and YouTube vloggers and
influencers has completely
changed the perception.
The fact that an entrepreneur
came out with a shoe
and sold it out to kids
in seconds is unreal.
High schoolers are paying more
and more attention to esports
and so is the world.
For example, Fortnite or Ninja,
the best player in the world,
played with Drake
JuJu Smith-Schuster
and then a rapper, Travis
Scott, as I mentioned earlier,
had over 600,000 people
viewing it at the same time.
Fashion is still really big
amongst today's young people.
Streetwear reigns supreme.
Teens today differentiate
themselves in many ways.
When it comes to fashion,
teens increasingly
choose like streetwear
brands, like Supreme and Vans,
over mainstream
brands, like Nike.
Supreme has this particular
kind of outsider appeal
for teenagers, even though
the brand launched in 1994,
in New York City, as a
skateboarding and clothing
company.
It caters to the skate
and hip hop cultures,
and to just youth
cultures in general,
and it's become an absolute
obsession for teenagers.
When teens hear about
a new shoe or product
launch on Reddit or other
social media, hundreds of teens
will line up in New York to get
their hands on their product
before it sells out.
And a lot of teens
are entrepreneurs.
They'll buy it
and then immediate
flip it for extreme
markups, and big finance
is starting to pay
attention to this.
The Carlyle Group
invested in Supreme
and valued the company at
over a billion dollars.
We have no interest in
working at big companies.
So most teens have
very little interest
in working for
major corporations,
even tech ones, like
Amazon and Facebook.
They've seen their
parents and older siblings
struggle in the workforce
and become unhappy,
despite these high paying jobs.
Teens today are more
entrepreneurial than older
generations and have less
patience for bureaucratic work
environments and crave
more independence.
72% of them said they wanted to
start a business one day, which
is pretty fascinating.
Number nine, you've left us
with a big mess to clean up.
Teens have grown
up watching reports
of a broken political
system, devastating climate
change, mass shootings at
schools, homegrown terrorism,
and ongoing war.
It's no surprise that like
68% of this generation
feel the US is headed
in the wrong direction,
and 44% are worried about the
way that things are going.
This was more than any other
generation interviewed.
And lastly, teens think that
we'll have a bigger impact
than you think.
It's easy for adults to
think that teens today
are pretty reckless.
Much of what we read
or hear in the media
focuses on the
negatives, like teens
trying to pull off
crazy stunts on YouTube,
which I'm sure you
have seen, or teens
infatuation with the JUUL.
Raise your hand if you've heard
of the JUUL, one person again.
The JUUL is a sleek e-cigarette
that can be used indoors
without attracting attention.
And don't get me wrong,
like the massive popularity
of this JUUL of e-cigarettes
is something that we
should be concerned about.
But the JUUL is something
that is massively
popular amongst teenagers,
but these types of behaviors
are really not much
different than what we
were like in prior generations.
And one teen described it
as just like the generations
before them, teens will always
want to rebel against the norm.
We're not worse.
It's just that you see it
more, because everything
is being recorded.
So focusing on these
negatives makes us lose
sight of the bigger picture.
What thousands of hours of
observing teens has shown me,
what many studies show,
is that today's teens,
they have a strong work
ethic and balance-forward
thinking with old-school,
traditional values.
So when adults think
about this new generation,
we should be open-minded.
Teens are multifaceted, and it's
going to take some time for us
to like stick with a name
for this next generation.
But when I asked
teenagers, like,
tell me if you can
name your generation.
What would you name it?
Here were some of the
responses that I got--
The Viral Generation, The
Founders, iGeneration,
Digital Natives, Gen Mobile,
Generation Next, The Connected
Generation, et cetera.
So these were some of the names.
These are some of
the names that I
got when I asked a bunch of
teenagers, how would you--
if you could name it, name your
generation, what would it be?
But regardless of
what they're called,
I think one thing
is really clear,
and that is that we
shouldn't underestimate
today's teenagers.
Yes, they use phones
in different ways
that we probably would
have never imagined.
They idolize these esports
stars that we've never heard of,
and they can be pretty quirky.
But they're already showing us
that they're going to step up
and tackle like major challenges
in ways that other generations
haven't.
Last weekend, like
March for Our Lives,
was one example that was
organized by teenagers.
It brought over 800,000
people to Washington DC
and countless more to
hundreds of sister marches
across the country.
This is more than the Inaugural
Women's March, the Million Man
March, and what else,
the March on Washington
for Jobs and Freedom.
800,000 was the
biggest march ever.
And today's teens, they have
energy, they have passion,
and they have a
no-nonsense attitude
about fixing the problems
that they've inherited.
And if what they've
accomplished in the last month
is any kind of
indication, we old people
are in pretty good hands.
So thank you for listening
to these ten points.
Hopefully, you learned
a little something today
in the 20 or 30 minutes
of time that I had,
and I'm happy to
answer any questions
that you have on today's
generation of teenagers.
AUDIENCE: So I know
that online bullying
is a uniquely bad problem
for this generation,
and I was curious what
your social network is
doing to mitigate that problem.
CORY LEVY: Yes.
So online bullying is a
very, very serious problem
for pretty much any
big social network.
One of the things that we
do is proactive moderation.
So most social networks
do reactive moderation.
When someone posts a message
to Twitter or Facebook,
it gets seen by everyone.
If it is a negative
message, it may
get taken down after the fact.
With After School, we
do product moderation.
So when someone
writes a message,
it has to get seen by
moderation in order for it
to get seen by others.
So that's one of the steps
that we take in After School,
and we hope that other social
networks will follow and just
increase moderation and yeah.
What's up in the back?
AUDIENCE: So streaks
definitely seems
like a pretty ingenious
gamification to encourage
more usage and so forth.
Any other examples of those
sorts of gamification elements,
whether in your social network
or others that you've seen?
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so in
other social networks,
obviously, likes is something
that teens care a lot about.
One of the things
that I've noticed
is that when a teenager
posts something on Instagram,
they will wait for like
five or ten minutes,
and if it doesn't get some
threshold number of likes,
they'll delete the post.
So likes is something that is
incredibly important to them,
and Snapstreaks is probably the
best example of gamification
that I've seen over the last
several years of following
this generation.
If Snap didn't have Snapstreaks,
I think teens would use it
way, way, way less.
And best friends, they
have another thing
called best friends.
I don't know if y'all know
what Snap best friends are,
but if you snap someone a bunch,
they'll have a little emoji
next to that person's name.
And each emoji may mean that
y'all are each best friends
with each other, one of you
is best-- if it's a wink,
it's one of you its best
friends with the other person,
but the other person's
not best friends with you.
So Snap's probably done the
best job of gamification,
and those are two
examples of that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that 70% of teens
want to have their own business,
if I heard you correctly.
CORY LEVY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
if this is related,
what do they think
of colleges, college
debt and nontraditional
[INAUDIBLE] things.
Do they also think
differently than like people
did in the past?
CORY LEVY: I'm sorry.
Could you speak up?
AUDIENCE: So I heard recently
that so many people have
college debt that
there's basically
there's a prognosis of people
who are freshmen this year,
40% will default on
student loans eventually.
So I wonder if there's also some
very interesting ideas, stuff
like how to not end
up being in debt.
Maybe they do something
different for a college
education.
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so I think
that most teens are still
following that traditional
path of going to high school,
graduating, going to
college, incurring this debt.
And then quickly
realizing when they
graduate that they
weren't trained properly
to enter the workforce.
So I don't think
we're there yet.
I hope one day that
we do get there,
where teens realize that
paying $200,000 over the course
of four years for
random X degree
may not mean that they're going
to get a high-paying job to pay
that off.
So I think teens, they care
so much about themselves
and their friends
that they don't really
know much about what that
means, what college means
and what going in debt
means, so yeah, not yet.
AUDIENCE: Also, do
you think there's
a big difference between high
schoolers and middle schoolers?
They use social media
in a similar way today?
CORY LEVY: So high schoolers
and middle schoolers
are completely different.
Some parents don't let
their middle schoolers
get Instagram or Snapchat
until they reach a certain age.
Some of the middle schoolers,
they're using Musical.ly.
They're starting their own
slime businesses on Instagram,
where they make
slime and sell it.
Middle schoolers,
I've seen like a bunch
of entrepreneurial
characteristics,
but I don't know
them super well.
But yeah, I do see
pretty big differences
from middle school, high
school, and college,
in terms of network use.
AUDIENCE: I have heard
about the detachment
from tech overall is the trend.
Would you say that it's
not a trend for teenagers
but for older generation?
CORY LEVY: What is the trend?
AUDIENCE: A detachment
from technology.
CORY LEVY: Oh, detachment
So I think teens, they're
very self-aware that they're
addicted to their phones.
If you go to a high school
and watch people during lunch,
like everyone will be like this.
Yesterday, we were with
a group of 80 teenagers,
and we were looking
at their Snap scores.
Snap score means when I send
one Snap message, I get a point.
When I receive a Snap message,
I get an additional point.
One teenager, and this was
kind of like the average,
had over 600,000
points, which means
the average was like she had
her Snapchat for a year or two
or three or whatever it was.
She was sending 14 snaps
an hour, 24 hours a day.
So I think teens are very
self-aware that they're
addicted to their phones,
but they don't really care.
I think when you go to
college, that's maybe
when you start to
figure out, how
do I manage my time
differently, and how can I
be more productive?
But today's teenagers are pretty
much like this all of the time.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
teenagers' perception of VR
is today?
CORY LEVY: Teenagers'
perception of VR?
I think some of the
longer tail of teenagers
are super interested
in it, and I
think they'll be like the early
adopters to the technology.
But the devices are expensive,
so it's kind of tough for them
to get their hands on it.
But yeah, I think the
younger generations generally
set those trends,
and I think VR will
be really big amongst them.
I think there's a question
to the right of you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to know a bit
more about the After School app
and how you think you won over
their trust to post things
like you showed us.
And also like how you
convince them that it's worth
their time to spend on the app.
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so
the first question
on how we kind of
win over their trust.
I think we built a
product for teenagers.
Most people don't do that.
Most people just build
a product for everyone,
and so our product was
built like just for them.
So they know when they
download the app that there's
a verification process.
They need to get past
a few number of things
to prove that they're a
teenager and that they
attend that high school.
So there's a level of
safety that they feel.
Like, when I'm
joining this network,
I had to jump through all these
hoops to prove I was a student,
and so I think that
they like that.
One high schooler was
telling me that they
posted some photo
on Facebook, and it
was like to impress a girl.
And the grandmother commented,
oh my god, you're so cute,
and that was like the last
time he used Facebook.
So I think people, teenagers,
are attracted to After School,
because it's just for them.
There are no grandparents.
There are no teachers
on the platform,
and it's a place where they
can just feel comfortable.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the question
is how did you convince them
it's worth their time?
Like, they have a bunch of other
stuff going on in high school.
CORY LEVY: Yeah.
That's a great question.
How do we convince them
that it's worth their time?
I don't have a perfect
answer to that question.
Our app's grown 100%
through word of mouth.
I think there's probably like
a really big demand needed
for teenagers to
be in this place
where it's just them
and their friends.
We all had that, or at least I
had that when I was growing up.
I had Facebook to go to
when I was in high school,
and there were no teachers
or parents on Facebook.
It was just me and my
high school buddies.
So I think there is a big
demand to create a space where
it's just them
and their friends,
and Snapchat kind of helps
a little bit with that.
Although, parents are
joining Snap a lot right now.
But yeah, so I think just
creating that space just
for them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just
had another question.
Did they say anything
about when they
think Snapchat is going to die
out or Instagram is going to?
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so I think
there is this kind of circle
that we see.
Where Facebook, they started
with the college audience.
Their audience kind
of grew up, and then
they started to build for
like a wider audience,
and then, they neglected
their original audience.
And neglected young
people, as they
wanted to just gain
more users and get
bigger numbers for investors
and their business.
So I think we're starting to
see a little bit of that right
now with Instagram
and Snapchat, where
their parents and
their grandparents
are starting to join
those platforms.
That will drive the teens
out something different.
Teens response to Instagram was,
well great, if my grandparents
and parents are
on this, I'm just
going to create this second
Instagram that they're not
going to know about.
With Snapchat, it's a
little bit harder to do,
but with Snap's new update, if
y'all are familiar with that,
that's like lowered the
engagement, I imagine,
massively amongst teenagers.
And the ones that I
talked to are like, yeah,
with the new update, I
don't use Discover anymore.
I don't-- they're on it less.
So I'm not sure that was
the best update for Snapchat
with respect to teenagers.
AUDIENCE: So how do you prevent
the parents or grandparents
to come to After School?
CORY LEVY: So how do we
prevent the old people
from infiltrating our network?
Basically, it's a
verification process.
So when you log
into the app, you
show us you're school ID
or verify in a certain way.
And that's similar to how
Facebook, when they started,
you had to verify with
your dot edu address
to prove that you are
a college student.
We do things similar.
AUDIENCE: So compared with this,
I feel that Google is so old.
Do any of you--
how many usage of your
audience actually use Google?
CORY LEVY: How many
actually use Google?
Well, they love Google,
because it helps them
with their homework, but
yeah, its the default web
browser for them.
So I think they're using
it from just probably how--
or at least how I used
it in high school which
was like if I want to know
anything, go to Google.
It helps me with my homework.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CORY LEVY: And that's
probably, I would imagine,
what they attribute
Google to the most
is like the thing that
helps me with my homework.
AUDIENCE: What's the one thing
that you believe about teens
that nobody else believes?
CORY LEVY: That
nobody else believes?
Well, I think teenagers--
I think adults think
teens are rebels,
and I think that they're too
addicted to their phones.
They're going to mess up
the whole next generation,
and I disagree with that.
I think that today's teenagers
are more capable than ever
to make change, and
we're seeing examples
of that with this March for
Our Lives demonstration.
Just to say that like
a few teenagers planned
this massive rally, you
would have never thought
that was possible five
years ago or ten years ago.
But with social media, with
Twitter, with Facebook,
with Instagram, et
cetera, you're able to--
one kid in a school is able
to make this massive change.
So I think this is like the
first really big example
of this, but we're
going to see so much
more of this in the days,
weeks, and years to come.
So and I imagine
if you interviewed
a bunch of old people,
they'd be like, no,
they're definitely
not, but that's
one thing I disagree with.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could speak more
to like the method of
collecting this information,
and if you have any
tips that you've
learned from methods that
worked well versus others that
might have been misleading.
CORY LEVY: To collect this
information about teenagers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so
that's a great question.
Teenagers have
different personas.
They're around their friends,
it's one way they act.
When they're around adults,
they act incredibly different.
So it's really challenging
to get real, true information
about teenagers.
So a couple of ways we
do it is, one, we luckily
have this app that millions of
teenagers are communicating on.
So we're able to pick
up trends in language
that they're using just from
the posts that they write.
Additionally, we have like
a bunch of ambassadors
across America, and we
ask them to help us.
Hey, text this to your friend.
Text these questions
to your friends.
Take a screen shot
of the people you
follow, the people you
subscribe to on YouTube,
so we can see like who
the big vloggers are.
So it's really tough.
Sometimes, we'll get adult
answers from teenagers,
and they'll be like
a capital letter.
They'll speak very formally, and
then other times, we'll get--
let's see.
I think I maybe put--
well, I guess I capitalized
most of the things,
but like the way that
kids are replying to me.
You could tell it was like
they're doing this like they're
texting one of their friends.
It's like totally incorrect
grammar, misspellings
everywhere.
And that's kind of one of the
indications of like, all right,
this person is being
really real versus
if they were typing like
real professionally,
but yeah, it's hard.
It's really, really hard.
People are biased,
but yeah, in short,
a couple of things
that we do is,
one, we use our own
platform, and two,
we have a group of
teen ambassadors
that will go and ask
the questions for us.
So it's a teenager
talking to a teen,
not an old person
talking to a teen.
AUDIENCE: So one question,
what happens after graduation
to the After School account?
CORY LEVY: For After School,
what happens after graduation
is they're kicked out.
Eventually, we'll build
a college product,
but to keep the network
just high schoolers,
we have to kick them out.
So we've kicked out
a million plus users.
One last question.
AUDIENCE: Do you
see-- so you said
that there was some
entrepreneurial spirit
among the teenagers, some
of the selling slimes.
That's probably why my
daughter is learning to smile
and is only eight years old.
Did you see any promising
entrepreneurial spirit
like some ideas a teenager--
CORY LEVY: Yeah, so
her question was,
she has an 8-year-old
daughter that's
making slime and selling it.
And is this generation-- do I
see any ideas from teenagers
that are trying to make change?
And I see it every day.
It's really cool.
There's one 18-year-old
that I'm working
with that's trying to make
vegan chicken nuggets to make
us all be vegetarians.
And trying to build
like a teen brand
and make being a
vegetarian cool.
And yeah, so that's just one
example of a teenager being
like this is a real problem.
And he's taking matters
into his own hands
and trying to create the vegan
version of McDonald's, and I've
seen that dozens of times.
So it's inspiring.
Thank you all for listening,
and hopefully, you're
a little bit more knowledge
on today's teenager.
[APPLAUSE]